Political comedies just as easy now as
it was during the Bush years.
It still,
um,
it's a different cast of characters,
but,
you know,
they've got all the same foibles.
Uh,
uh,
personally,
you know,
speaking for myself,
I certainly like,
and,
and trust our president now more than I
did our previous one.
But,
uh,
he makes plenty of,
goofs,
uh,
I,
I certainly don't approve of everything
he does.
And,
and there's a cast of characters in
Washington right now that are,
uh,
you know,
absolutely.
As hilarious as,
as anyone who was there during the Bush
years,
we're always looking to keep it fresh
and,
and that's not so much because we need,
we're scared we're going to lose the
audience.
It's more,
we don't want to lose our own interests.
Uh,
you know,
you,
you do the show four days a week,
you know,
however many weeks a year,
you can get bored by doing it.
So we have to keep making it exciting
for ourselves.
So there's absolutely,
there's,
there,
there's that and it was like,
let's try something new,
even though it might be hard.
And there's also,
um,
you know,
we're,
it's a group of very competitive,
funny people and we'd like to make each
other laugh.
So,
you know,
we're,
we know what a standard show could be
and we're always trying to break out of
that just so we can impress each other.
Absolutely not.
No,
I,
uh,
the hardest part for me in a work
environment is collaboration.
Uh,
it's that,
that's just a struggle I've always had.
And I,
I,
I love my coworkers and I love,
uh,
you know,
bouncing ideas around with them.
But,
uh,
I really enjoy pure riding,
just sitting and writing by myself.
Um,
you know,
and every show is different.
This is,
this is the most collaborative
environment I've ever been in.
I used to ride on a TV show called news
radio where,
uh,
it was very different.
We didn't have a,
uh,
any sort of big table or anything where,
where ideas are bounced around.
We Really,
uh,
you'd come up with a script idea and
you'd go off and write it.
You need to hand it to the next guy up
the food chain.
And he would rewrite it.
It was,
you know,
it was,
uh,
as pure writing experience as you can
get an insert of the TV world.
The main difference between the two is
just the immediacy there,
the daily show,
the news hits,
and we get,
we get to take care of it that night.
Uh,
the simpsons,
such a strange animal,
um,
and a wonderful animal,
but a strange one,
you would be writing for something that
wouldn't air for nine months to a year
and,
and it's still,
people would go,
wow,
how did you get that reference?
You know,
so quickly.
And,
and,
and uh,
you know,
frequently it would seem like,
uh,
the show was present.
Um,
I,
I enjoyed the simpsons,
but I tell you what,
I,
I like the immediacy of the daily show
more.
It,
it was free.
It's frustrating to write something and
then not see the finished product,
uh,
for,
a year,
uh,
with the daily show.
It's like you're really putting on a
show.
You know,
I'm,
I'm Mickey Rooney,
uh,
you know,
I'm writing a script and that night it
goes live.
And if it's terrible,
well,
we'll do another show tomorrow night.
Oh,
absolutely.
Yeah.
We're,
we're,
we're not so different from everybody
else.
It's not like I'm particularly funny in
this interview anyway,
so,
uh,
you know,
we don't always have to be funny.
How's that?
Um,
you,
um,
uh,
W I,
I think we can be just as adequate at
managing people as others and,
you know,
and it,
look,
it's,
it's all management skills that go into
our wheelhouse.
It's,
uh,
okay.
I,
I read a script.
This isn't funny.
This is what you need to do.
Boop,
boop,
uh,
it's,
if I were an accountant,
I'd be able to point out,
uh,
where the numbers didn't add up.
Um,
you know,
if I'm watching a montage and this
doesn't go together quite right,
I,
it as someone who is a professional is a
comedy professional.
Uh,
I,
I can point out what's going to work
better.
No,
I tell you what,
it,
everyone at the show is so nice and,
and,
and so shockingly competent that it,
it's,
uh,
it's not a real problem.
Uh,
I've been in situations where,
um,
there've been people who are difficult
to,
people who just didn't want to be
around,
uh,
people you had to manage more heavily.
I,
there's nothing like that there.
It's a,
and I think a lot of that has to do
with,
with the fact that it's such a fast
moving machine.
Anyone who,
who acts as any sort of,
uh,
sand in the gears get spit out pretty
quickly.
Okay.